[Music]  so that's the ex-girlfriend is it  the old ex-girlfriend judy foster gene  foster the one that got away the one  that got away that means escaped yeah  yeah  must be hard for you to see your  ex-girlfriend and your ex hammer hanging  out and getting on so well  what you up to bro  daddy  [Music]  hey  there you are  hey  i was just calling you  [Music]  there's the maniac who seeks to end us  all  i'm putting together the greatest team  ever are you packed  yes  [Music]  valkyrie this is the best day of my life  the audience  they also scream quite a lot  [Music]  you said this would be a relaxing  holiday  i said it was going to be like a  relaxing holiday  human handshake  to the asgardian shake  into the snake  that you cannot trust  really dragging us out and finish the  classic asgardian high one  it theaters july 8 tickets on sale now  [Music]  you